on exige l'exemple mais on se dispense
de le donner sept citations
philosophiques de joseph tanny al dib
est issu de son livre les pensées sur
l'homme le monde et les moeurs prend
tout son sens aujourd'hui
oui le port du masque est désormais
obligatoire dans les lieux publics clos
oui il faut respecter les gestes
barrières pour lutter efficacement
contre le courant l'a virus les actes
sont bien souvent préféré au mot et
certains membres du gouvernement aurait
tendance à l'oublier
dernier exemple en date la ministre
chargé de la citoyenneté célèbre
l'anniversaire d'une personne âgée lors
d'une visite officielle avec gerald
d'arman 93 ans as fait plaisir d'être
invité à l'improviste à trinquer à la
santé de cet arrière grand père réunis
avec toute la famille à côté de calais
joyeux anniversaire monsieur ce tweet
n'existe plus immédiatement supprimées
après de multiples commentaires
d'internautes sur le simple fait d'aller
souhaiter l'anniversaire d'un
nonagénaire en pleine crise du pot vide
10 900 porcs correcte du masque et une
distanciation sociale quasi inexistante
avec des personnes à risque
autre tweet vendredi a posté par la
secrétaire d'état aux sports roxana
maracineanu en compagnie de jean michel
blanquer elle son ministre de tutelle
les deux en visite au creps de
montpellier pour rencontrer les équipes
de france de judo honteux aussi
semble-t-il oublié le mètre de distance
et leurs masques comme du reste est tous
les athlètes sur cette photo mais le
moment le plus flagrant en date
certainement du 7 juillet dernier lors
de la passation de pouvoirs dans les
ministères
là les images se passe de tout
commentaire
[Applaudissements]
si on a droit à tout
une succession d'erreurs largement
pointé du doigt sur les réseaux sociaux
alors que le gouvernement appelle à la
vigilance sur un possible regain de
l'épidémie on est en droit de se
demander si le devoir d'exemplarité est
remise en cause